the minimalists want to help you avoid
impulse purchases that's why we created
five questions to ask before buying
which is now a wallpaper for your
smartphone
now you'll always have a reminder when
you're getting ready to purchase
something new
head on over to theminimalists.com
before
to download your free wallpaper today
how do i appropriately let go of
well-crafted handmade gifts
without offending the givers so
we've already addressed gift giving
and gift getting but then there becomes
a point when you receive something
and i think it can go three ways either
you get a men's value from it
great you're gonna hold on to that right
you feel good about the gift that you
got
maybe it was a nice bag of coffee and
you go through it a bottle of wine a bar
of chocolate
and you're able to consume it or maybe
it's some sort of widget that you
and your family get value from that's
great and then i think
there are two other avenues that we
might take
one is we got the gift we got some value
from it we're no longer getting value
from it
and so now the thing that we once got
value from is now clutter it's
turned into junk for us we serve it a
purpose during a season that season's
over
now it no longer serves us purpose or
maybe we were given something
and it never suited us maybe it never
was appropriate for our lives someone
had good intentions in giving it to us
but now
all of a sudden we've realized i'm not
getting much out of this
meg what do we do when we have one of
those things it's no longer serving a
purpose in our life we were given
given that gift but we're gonna feel
guilty if
we decide to let go of it now yes so
part of where that guilt stems from is
you know someone
spent a lot of money their hard-earned
money on it or you think they spent a
lot of time
searching for this gift or they spent a
lot of time making the gift
so that's where this guilt is stemming
from um
the first thing to do if it feels like
it could be an appropriate situation
is to be honest and say
you know hi i've gone through i'm doing
different type of decor
or i'm scaling back on my decor and
going through things
or my stuff if we're talking about gifts
in general
and i i i'm not going to use this
anymore
but i wanted to tell you first and ask
you first if you wanted it back
before i give it to you know ask another
friend
and give it another life or give it to
the thrift shop and
let someone else enjoy it and use it
because it just feels like a waste right
now that no one's able to
appreciate the beauty of this item or to
use this item
i mean that's selfish to hold on to it
and it's in a way
so i would first go to the person and
ask them
if they would like it back and you can
say that with i don't mean to offend you
i just
we're scaling back on things right now
yeah and i wanted to give you the option
first so either they can decide whether
it's so precious
to them that they can't imagine it going
to a thrift shop
or to a dumpster and they can take it
back and decide what to do with it
either it can
remain clutter in their house or maybe
they will find appreciation and place
for it and use for it
if not they can say they can help give
you that permission that you might think
you need
of oh don't worry about it yeah if you
don't need that anymore it's it's
it's nothing do what you need to do with
it right and so that's a great thing
but definitely don't let them guilt you
and then there's some things where you
can discern
i probably shouldn't let my mother know
that i'm just going to quietly
release this she probably will never
notice
and if you can feign some sort of
ignorance if she ever does
yeah i mean of course you don't ever
want to lie
to your family but i think sometimes the
best time to have that conversation is
if they do notice but you don't have to
preemptively have the conversation
if it was some sort of thing that you've
i think with most of these things
once you've gotten rid of it most people
aren't going to notice if i went to
someone's house and
they didn't have the gift that i got i
wouldn't even think twice aren't you
wearing my tie clip
that i gave you i am i'm just not going
to show you where
oh but you know i yeah uh yeah i always
say like
you know when someone gives you a gift
they intend to give
to bring you joy in your life to give
you something that's going to make you
happier
and if you hold on to something and it's
not making you happier
then that is doing the opposite of what
they intended to do with that gift
so uh when you go i think when you go to
someone
and you have that conversation of hey
i'm thinking about letting this go do
you want to back or
i could find a good home for it um which
is like i did that with my grandma with
a paperweight she gave me a paperweight
she's like i know that you
you have a lot of paper you're a writer
so you have a lot of papers like i don't
you know like she's imagining that i
have stacks of papers all over
my house and and right yeah
she gave me a paperwork i'm like oma um
she literally gave you a
paperweight i want people to listening
to this it was a beautiful paperweight
i want you to think like we use that as
a metaphor
for a useless gift right she actually
gave you a paperwhite yeah
so i'm like i'm like oma this is
beautiful and it was from germany it was
a beautiful paperweight
um she stashes these little gifts to
like give people so like i don't even
know how old it was
um i'm like this is something i'm not
going to use i said but what i will do
is i will find this a really really good
home if you'd rather me do that or i can
just give it back to you and she was
like we find it a good home and i was
like yeah i certainly will
she's like okay you go and find it a
good home um but she realized that like
that paper weight it was going to
actually add more stress into my life
than joy
so because she loves me and because she
wants me to be happy
she totally supported my decision to to
get rid of it and because you did a good
job
talking communicating with her yeah
because
it there there could have been a bunch
of different ways where you hurt her
feelings
and um you you
you yourself weren't being deliberate
you know there are a bunch of ways where
you could have that could have gone that
way you did the opposite you're very
deliberate about the communication that
you used
and and you didn't do the blaming
shaming your name you just say
hey what is this what is this crap or uh
grandma i can't believe you'd get me a
paperweight right you may even be
thinking that it might be your first
thought but it's inappropriate to
communicate that way
and so what you did is is you expressed
to her that you
you knew what she was trying to
communicate there and you know what it
goes back to what i was saying in the
minimal episode with
anything negative i put on myself and
all the positive i put under her so it
was like
you know i personally don't find uh
i won't i don't have a use for this
paperweight um you're such an amazing
home i know that you're being really
thoughtful and loving
um but actually i feel a little bit of
you know pressure to keep this and
i don't want to have to feel that
pressure i mean that is it's the yeah
you're right if i was like
what's your problem you know i'm a
minimalist i can't believe you'd
you'd add this stress to my life i mean
that would have been a completely
different
uh conversation you recognize the value
and the beauty that she saw in it you
recognize
you give gratitude and you say thank you
so much for thinking of me
thank you so much for gifting this to me
this is a beautiful
object this is a beautiful and useful
object
even as a paperweight it does hold down
papers for someone
you know so just recognizing when you
express that to somebody
they see that you appreciated what they
appreciated in it
yeah so that's a good part of setting it
up yes